Why do I know I discussed religious fundamentalism more often and more in depth.
Many people consider you a religious apologist as a consequence.
Well,
it's okay if people considered me a religious apologist.
I am a religious apologist.
So an apologist is someone who makes an argument for something.
And I'm constantly making arguments for a religious perspective on life or
religious orientation towards life.
Uh,
uh,
an orientation that's centered in,
in meaning,
I know orientation that's centered in desire for all things to thrive in so far
is that it's possible desire for people to speak the truth and act out the truth
and act responsibility,
act responsibly,
and all of that.
And I think that there's some something transcendently necessary about all of
that.
And I think it is the antidote to hell.
So that that makes me a religious apologist.
The fundamentalists,
I dunno.
Which fundamentalists you mean if you mean the Christian fundamentalists?
Well,
I understand where they're coming from.
You know,
I think the Christian
Christianity is an ethical framework above all else.
And it's predicated in a story about the way the world is constituted and,
and the story provides the foundation for that ethic and the ethic unites the
community and gives people direction.
This is a big deal.
Now,
if the story is challenged,
if the foundational stories challenged,
which is certainly what happened as a consequence of the rise of empirical
science,
then the foundation for the ethic starts to,
okay,
starts to shake and tremble.
And that threatens the ethic.
But the ethic is what holds people together and gives them direction.
So you can't just lose the ethic.
So the fundamentalist Christians are all short circuited because they know that
there's something to the ethic and they understand that the foundation has been
shaken,
but they don't know what to do about it.
So they insist that the foundation has not been shaken.
And I understand that.
So I think the way out of that is to understand that
the truth that govern ethics and the truths that govern the description of the
world as a material place are not the same.
They're not,
they're not.
They're not of the same kind.
Um,
how they're related.
I'm not exactly sure,
but there's no simple one to one relationships.
You can't describe the world and then immediately extract out in ethic.
It's partly because there are just too many ways of describing the world.
So,
and this is the,
that the fundamental point of difference as far as I can tell between Sam Harris
and I and hopefully what we'll discuss in the summer.
So,
so that's the Christian fundamentalists and I don't really see that they're a
particularly threatening group as far as I can tell.
I mean there are certainly not in the ascendance by any stretch of the
imagination.
Um,
they're not involved in any particularly reprehensible political behavior unless
you count conservatism.
And it is by no means obvious that they're even holding their ground in the
culture war.
So I'm not very worried about them.
Um,
Islamic fundamentalism,
that's a whole different story.
But I don't know enough about it to discuss it intelligently.
I don't understand Islam.
It,
it,
I'm concerned about.
It's,
what would you call compatibility with,
with the Democratic West?
It isn't obvious to me that there are medium to high functioning Muslim
democracies.
I suppose turkeys the closest one,
but Turkey's pretty soon,
pretty shaky at the moment.
I think that the failure to separate church and state,
or even if we don't call it a failure,
the fact that church and state hasn't been technically separated in Islam makes
it difficult to understand how it's possible for Islam and modern western
democratic traditions to coexist.
I don't know how that can be,
that gap can be bridged.
Um,
you could say,
well with goodwill and let's,
let's hope that's the case.
Um,
that doesn't mean I don't think that Muslims can live in a modern western
democracy.
I mean there are many,
many kinds of Muslims just like there are many kinds of Jews and Christians.
And so,
and then there's the problem of the current proclivity of the extreme end of the
Muslim fundamentalist world to become,
to be very violent in very many ways.
And so,
you know what,
I'm not a great admirer of the Saudis to say the least.
I don't appreciate their brand of,
of Wahhabi Islam.
And I don't appreciate their exports of that view with their petro dollars to
the rest of the world.
So
I guess that's what I have to say about fundamentalists.
Hello,
Dr. Peterson.
I've been trying to listen to my conscience,
but I can't tell the difference between fear,
willful blindness or genuine conscience.
Well,
the first thing I would say about that is it is quite clear that you are in fact
to listen to your conscience because that's probably the first thing that you
discover.
So that's a really good question.
Okay.
Fear.
Well,
here's the test and you don't want to do this stupidly.
If you think that you should do something and you think that the reason you
might not be doing it is because you're afraid,
then you should do it.
Okay?
So that way you can find out if it's fear.
You know,
I think your question is,
well,
how do I know my conscience isn't just masquerading as fierce saying,
you shouldn't do that,
but it's rationalizing the real issue,
which is you're afraid of doing that.
Now,
see,
here's a reason that you want to tell the truth.
And I parked,
I kind of figured this out when I was looking deeply into the Pinocchio Story.
You know,
in Pinocchio as Pinocchio strives to become real,
he,
he has a conscience to guide him,
but it's jimminy cricket,
this insect.
But Jimmy hasn't really a very good conscience.
He's a bit dogmatic to begin with.
Dogmatic and inexperienced.
And so it's,
it's not like the conscience is an unerring guide.
It's like a partner in discovery.
And as you move forward in your life and you consult your conscience and you
listen to it,
then it gets smarter and so to you.
But there's a code of their,
and this is why I've suggested part of the reason why I've suggested so
frequently in my lectures and in my book that people try not to lie.
You see,
there are many systems,
you have many systems within,
let's say,
that guide you.
And one of those is your capacity for rational thought.
And then you have a variety of emotional systems and motivational systems and
internal dramas and uh,
intuitions and bodily sensations like lots and lots of and senses,
lots of systems that are guiding you.
And many of them operate,
you might say,
unconsciously,
autonomously,
instinctively,
implicitly,
all of that.
Now you PR nonetheless,
you programmed them like you feed them content,
let's say just like you feed your body nourishment,
you feed them content and a lot of the content that you feed them pertains
directly to your voluntary thoughts and speech and your actions.
And then if you pathologize those by lying.
So if you say things that you know not to be true or you don't say things that
you know to be true when you need to,
which is more common.
And if you act in ways that you consider that act in ways you considered
reprehensible,
then you pathologize all of those autonomous systems that guide you.
It's like you're programming them badly,
you're building an AI system inside yourself really in,
in,
in some sense that is what you're doing that has very bad,
it's very bad training data.
And so the output it produces will be well,
won't guide you properly.
And so you don't want to pathologize your guidance systems.
It's a really bad idea.
So that's why you have to not lie.
And maybe that's also why you have to say what you have to say.
And you have to say it clearly as well.
And you have to learn how to do that.
So that's one of the ways of getting your conscience straightened out.
And then you have to have a dialogue with your conscience.
And you might ask,
it's like,
okay,
well what should I do?
Or what should,
should I do this or should I not do this?
So let's say you're thinking,
should I not do this?
In the case of a temptation,
maybe you have a chance to develop a new relationship.
You know,
and you're,
you're excited about it and apprehensive about it and afraid of it and you don't
know how to sort out all those feelings.
And the first thing is you really have to want to sort them out.
That's why you have to orient yourself to something that's a genuine up.
You know that the star above the horizon,
you have to really want things to be straight and you have to have thought that
through.
And you have to know what it means for things not to be straight.
And really what it means is that you're headed for hell in one way or another.
And if you understand that it's enough,
maybe it's enough to scare you straight,
you really got to think that through.
Then you've got to think about how much better it would be if you aimed up.
And that really has to kind of permeate your whole being.
And so then you're oriented that way.
You're oriented to dop and you're deciding that it's okay to try to tell the
truth and then you can start to rely on this dialogue with your conscience.
But both of you have to learn and you're going to make mistakes along the way.
You know that's okay.
You can say,
well,
I'm going to try this without being certain that it's right.
You can even say,
I'm going to say this without being certain that it's correct.
Like if you're arguing with your wife or your husband or your,
or your sister,
your father,
and you have an idea about what might be going on,
you can say,
look,
here's my idea about what's going on.
Um,
who knows what that idea might be contaminated with,
like maybe I'm putting it forward just because I'm too proud or arrogant or
angry or fearful or whatever.
That's possible.
Let's see if we can figure that out.
But you can offer it tentatively and both have added.
That's what you do if it's a hypothesis,
right?
You both have at it and see if it's an idea that's worthy of,
of keeping you do that with your conscience and then you were move forward.
There's a,
there's a technique in behavioral psychology called psychotherapy called
collaborative empiricism.
So let's say that we,
you and I have been sitting down and we decided that you're going to try
something new this week,
like maybe your agoraphobic and you're having a hard time in a parking lot.
And so getting out of the car and going to the grocery store.
So maybe we say,
well,
you know,
to drive to the grocery store and you're just going to walk halfway to the
halfway from your car to the door.
And that's good enough for like do that every second day for a week and then
come back and let's talk about it.
So that's collaborative empiricism,
you're running a little experiment,
you think,
well your conscience is guiding you towards something.
You take a tentative step in that direction and then you check and see,
well,
you know,
did what I wanted to have happen ochre as an outcome.
That's the crucial question and that's the crucial question for behavioral
truth,
right?
That's the pragmatic perspective.
Did what I want to have happen happen as a consequence of my framework of
interpretation and my action.
If the answer is yes,
then I have not invalidated it.
Right?
That's,
that's the pragmatic philosophy in a nutshell and it's,
it's very,
very smart.
So you have a dialogue with your conscience that never ends,
and hopefully it gets wiser and you get wiser.
And
that's the dialogue that young talked about between the conscious and the
unconscious,
between your,
your fantasy life,
say the life that sort of underneath you as a conscious being like you're the
life that's part of your biological platform,
the biological platform that somehow miraculously gives rise to your
consciousness.
If a dialogue with that,
we're always in dialogue.
We're always in dialogue,
right,
with everything.
So
pursue that.